ah who doesn't love a good dip in a
kiddie pool
however cautiously you may go about it
coffee bars aren't native to kiddie
pools instead you can find them in the
waterways of South America this is the
world's largest rodent how largest
exactly think 175 pounds that's heavier
than your average human male not an
American human male mind you definitely
not heavier than that the copy' bar has
a certain angry slash baked look to it
like a STONER who just now found out
pee-wee's Playhouse got cancelled
copy bars are way chill this one here is
tight with a monkey and the copy bar is
certainly the family type one male
claims control of a group while the
females share childcare duties now
you'll notice that the copy bars eyes
and ears and nose are all on top of its
head that's because this giant rodent
spends a good amount of its life
puttering around ponds and rivers
keeping all those senses above the
waterline helps it spot predators like
Jaguars and these webbed feet help repel
the copy Barra as it searches for
vegetation to eat including but not
limited to marijuana I jest of course
capybara say no to drugs though I do
have my suspicions hello